عرضي التقديمي بلغة إنجليزية
ولكني أود أن أعتذر
للمنظم ، أود المضي قدمًا
والقيام بذلك باللغة العربية ، سأبدأ هذه
الصفحة باللغة الإنجليزية فقط ، هل يمكنك رؤية
اسمي فينت تمتم في حياتي
هناك  العديد من الفرص وهام ديل
وكنت محظوظًا بما يكفي لتغيير أشياء كثيرة
في حياتي والتي أثرت بشكل إيجابي على
البيئة المحيطة وعندما أقول
البيئة أعني الإنسان بالإضافة
إلى نوع آخر من دعوة نوع آخر من
عناصر البيئات الأخرى ،
اسمي ميريام  حميد مادارا حميد وإذا كانت
إحدى مهمتي لدي خططي منذ
عام 2012 2050 لدي خطتي وأعلم ما
يجب أن أفعله وحتى الآن كنت محظوظًا بما يكفي
لتحقيق كل خطتي في نفس
الموعد النهائي إن لم يكن قبل ذلك ومتى  من
عشيرتي في عام 2000 قبل عام 2050 ، إذا كنت
سأعيش على قيد الحياة ، فسيتم تغيير جميع أسمائنا في الوثائق الرسمية
لتصبح مريم بنثام حمد بن فاطمة
حيث سيتم ذكر أمهاتنا
أيضًا ، لذا أود دعمكم
لنبدأ من اليوم للتأكد من
ذكر اسم والدتنا هناك وربما
لن يوافق بعضكم على ما
أحترمه ولكني أعتقد أن والدتنا كانت
تستحق أن يتم تسميتنا إذا
كنا سنغير أي شيء في التاريخ
بصفتي نساء مبتريات أذهب  وألتقي امرأة أخرى ناعمة
من مناطق مختلفة من العالم
، وأحد الموضوعات الرئيسية التي ستبدأ
المناقشة بها هو
المنافسة بين الإناث والذكور
وكيف لا يعاملون بشكل جيد أو لا
يعتنون بأحدهم مرة أخرى.
شخصيًا على مستواي الشخصي
كامرأة إماراتية ، كنا محظوظين بما يكفي
لوجودها في بلد زيبس
، وكنا محظوظين جدًا بوجود
رجل نبيل يحيط بنا ، لذا أود
اليوم من خلال هذا المؤتمر
والمنتدى الإيجابي أن نجتاز نجاحًا كبيرًا-
رسالة شكر محددة لجميع السادة الطيبين
في حياتي الذين حصلوا على أكبر دعم
وأكبر تأثير على وجودي حيث
أكون ، أعترف بأن والدتي لعبت دورًا كبيرًا
في تطوير مهاراتي بشكل خاص.
والسلوك الحكيم بينما
والدي وأخي زوجي
قادتي كان لهم التأثير الأكبر على
الأبعاد الأخرى لتطور حياتي المهنية
وخاصة في البحث والقيادة
في عام 2006 كنت
سأمتلكها بما يكفي لا تستطيع حاضنة فيورينا مشاركتها كثيرًا
وهي الانتظار  كلمة باللغة الماراثية ، نعم ، هذا
ما أود أن أكون وحشًا ، أيكيدو هو إيريكا الساحل ،
لا يمكن أن يكون رأسه ، يمكن للكبير أن يخبرنا
عندما تسمي إيفيت هاجا هوما وهو
بروك فييرا حسنًا يمكنني أن أقول ذلك مع
الخوف العرقي من الأحمر ولكن نيك هنا دقيقة
دان و  جمل نينا أكدال المتجمعة وراء
الطريق يتضاءل الشيعة في اللون الأبيض
الموجب كان موجبًا لا يمكن أن يزيل كل
شعر من أطفال الأنابيب وجهين في
رسوم آنا أوكتوروك أكشاي.
مسجد الحسن الثاني
امرأة مع المجلد مايو
بعد وفندق ماكالين واضح ميلكا وات
كانما جوديث جدا عندما
اتصل القائد هنا في ماهان الصافية
هاكون هايدن ماككل  عين أبي
يتم تهريبه رئيس التضامن مع آلان
فيرمينتينو الراوي موفاسا وهو
أكاديمي غير جامد أفضل على عثمان
إماراتي في الجسد في Unisa Yahoo يرث
Manasa نبات وحيد حسن
فورزا I ويتني مريح mon-sat PID دعنا
نحرك الرجال في الهواء لعبوا  هي في
حكمها ، أي واحد منا كلما كان
في أي منصب قيادي
أو أي تحدٍ عليه أن
يتأكد من أن ما
حصل عليه سيحافظ عليه وسيحتفظ
به لبقية فريقه ، وهذا
ما يحدث قبل أن  تركت الوزارة ، لقد
تأكدت من وجود ثلاث عشرة امرأة في
منصب قيادي في وزارة
الصحة والآن يفعلون ذلك في
المنزل ، حتى أن بعضهن يعملن
بشكل أفضل بكثير من
زملائهن الذكور في
الوزارات في عام 2009 hamdulillah مرة أخرى
لقد رقي صاحب السمو الشيخ
محمد بن راشد آل مكتوم لأكون أول امرأة في منصب
مدير عام في حكومة دبي
وعضوًا في المجلس التنفيذي
.
إذا جعلناهم يحيطون بي ما لاحظته
للأسف في بيئتنا ، فإن
قادتنا يؤمنون كثيرًا بالنساء
ولكن ليس اللوز يؤمنون بالمرأة
ودائمًا ما يحاولون وضعك في
موقف صعب فقط لمحاولة
إسقاطك ولكن يؤمنون  أنا
كامرأة وكماراثية ومع كل
الرسائل الإيجابية التي تلقيتها اليوم
من المتحدث السابق ، قررت
الاستمرار ، لم يكن الأمر سهلاً على الإطلاق ، كان من
الصعب جدًا كل يوم أحتاج إلى مواجهة
تحدٍ جديد ولكن مرة أخرى مع الفريق
كنت أصر على أنني
سأكون قادرًا على القيام بذلك وقد فعلت ذلك في
إحدى المناسبات التي لن أنسى فيها أبدًا
عندما كنت المدير العام لدبي
في هيئة تنمية المجتمع
في أحد الاجتماعات حيث نحتاج إلى
اذهب ووضع اللمسات الأخيرة على قرار بشأن
الأيتام في دبي وخاصة أولئك الذين
هم مع عائلات لا تعرفهم ، لذلك
عندما ذهبنا إلى الاجتماع وفي
الاجتماع كانوا جميعًا من الذكور كنت
الأنثى الوحيدة في ذلك المكان التي اعتقدت أنني
محظوظ.  نعم ، لكن للأسف عندما جلست في
ذلك المكان وبدأنا في مناقشة
موضوع حساس للغاية ، رأيت دعنا نقول
اتصالًا غير صحي بالطريقة التي ركز بها
الذكر الآخر في الاجتماع
على موضوع واحد
بشكل غير مباشر أن هؤلاء الأطفال
في الشارع أو هؤلاء  أطفال أطفال
ليس لديهم آباء لمجرد
أن امرأة ارتكبت خطأً مع
رجل آخر كان فقط ذكرًا وليس رجل نبيل
وانتهى بها الأمر بإنجاب هذا الطفل ولم
ينتقد أي منهم ذلك الذكر الذي
كان سبب قدوم هذا الطفل
لن تكون السيدة قادرة على القيام بذلك بمفردها ، فأنا لا
أدافع عن هذا السلوك غير الجيد من
بعض النساء ولكن عندما نتحدث عن
إنسان في أي بيئة ،
لا ينبغي لنا أن ننتقد النساء أو الرجال
علينا أن ننتقد الموقف ونجعل
تأكد من العثور على حل كيف يمكننا
التأكد من أن الأمور يمكن أن تسير بشكل أفضل ،
سيكون لدى الأشخاص نزاهتهم
بطريقة أفضل خاصة الأطفال الجدد ،
لذلك عندما نجري هذه المناقشة ، كان علي
أن أوقفها في مكان ما ولكن لدي  للقيام بذلك
بطريقة مهذبة للغاية لا تتعارض
مع ثقافتنا ، أعني أن ثقافتنا
حساسة ولكننا مُعرّفين جيدًا
أنها مبنية على سنوات من الخبرة من
أجدادنا ، لذا فإن ما
فعلته لم أفعله  لإيقاف المناقشة عن طريق
مطالبتهم بالتوقف عن ذلك ، لا تلوم النساء لا
تتحدث عن تلك السيدة ، يرجى الشعور بالأسف
على هؤلاء الأطفال ، لقد سألت أحد
الرجال هناك وقلت هل يمكنك أن تتخيل
نفسك يومًا ما حيث كان الشر
يحيط بك و  لأنك وجدت
سيدة جميلة جدًا في زاوية من مكان
لا يمكن لأحد أن يراك فيه وقد
ارتكبت هذا الخطأ وكان هذا الصبي
ابنك ، ما كنت ستفعله من أجل هذا ،
هل تجلس وتلقي باللوم عليه أو
عندما يكبر.  سيذهب إلى المدرسة
وسيكون في نفس مدرسة ابنك ،
حيث يشبهون بعضهم البعض وقد تم
حظر شيء ما ،
يجب إجراء اختبار الحمض النووي وهم يعلمون
أنه ابنك في أي
وقت ستشعر فيه بالخجل  ستشعر بالخجل
لأنك تركت ابنك في مثل هذه الوضعية
في عدم معرفة من أنت والده
أو الشعور بالخجل لأنك كنت
سبب هذا الخطأ الكبير في الحياة ، لذلك
كان النقاش يسير بطريقة
مختلفة وقبل مغادرتي ، على الرغم من أنني
كنت مسؤولاً عن ذلك الاجتماع ، لم أفعل  لم أطلب
منهم اتباع قراري فقلت
لنأخذ استراحة لمدة نصف
ساعة وسنعود وسنرى كيف
كنا نضع علامة على هذا الموضوع
بفخر نقول اليوم al
hamdulillah rabbil alameen لدينا جميع الأطفال
في  مدينة دبي لدينا حمد الله
في مختلف هم تحت
مظلة سياسة وإجراءات
تحميهم من كل شيء في
البيئة لحمايتهم في
المجتمع وهم يعيشون مثل
أي طفل آخر في المدرسة بدون
اسم مع خاص
أو  العائلة حيث يتم ترشيحهم من قبل
والديهم وليس
الوالدين البيولوجيين ، شخص ما
سيأخذهم ويتبناهم وسيكونون في
حالة جيدة ما يجعلني ما
يجلب لي في هذا الموضوع والتأكيد
عليه مرة أخرى باعتباره  نحن امرأة في العالم
العربي والكثير من النساء الأخريات يطلبون دائمًا
حق المرأة بحق المرأة ، فأنا
ضد ذلك لأننا لسنا حق المرأة
ولا نريد أن نكون متساوين مع الله
لنحصل على كل الامتيازات مثلنا
أخي الذكر نود أن نحظى بمعاملة
محترمة وأن نحصل على ما نحتاج إليه لسنا بحاجة إلى
المزيد بصفتي امرأة أنا فخورة
بكوني أمريكية محميّة
، ولديها دعم كبير من جميع
السادة في البار في الإمارات العربية المتحدة  وأنا
أتحدث عن ذلك بمفرده لأنه حيث
تلقيت كل أنواع الدعم بدأ
مع سمو الشيخ منه أديلا
أفيلا ، لذا بصفتي امرأة ما زلت أريد
شخصًا ما يفتح لنا الباب لنا سيدات
أولاً
كامرأة ما زلت أريد.  للحصول على
إجازة الأمومة لمدة شهرين كامرأة ، ما
زلت بحاجة لأخذ ما زلت أحبني
كامرأة لا أعرف ،
سأعتذر لأنني لست متأكدًا من أنني لست قادرًا
على التركيز جيدًا
لأنني التقيت الآن بأحد المتحدثين مما
أثر علي كثيرًا ولا أعرف ما
هو اسمه S.  المعزقة لا د.  أحمد عمران
الله يرحمهم كما تعلم وعندما أريد
أن أتحدث عن إنجازاتي أشعر أنهم
لا شيء أمام شخص مثل
محمد عمران حسنًا ، فهم فقط
فصل دراسي صغير الآن أرى أنه يمكن أن تكون ليزا
هويرتا الآن ملكك
NSHE الذي  قل الله ، الله ،
الله بعد الآن يرشد أمريكا إلى
الأمام ويملأ خطاب مارتي نعم
كامرأة ، هناك تحد كبير للغاية
أن تكون امرأة خاصة في
هذا الجزء من العالم مع كل
الإيجابيات
وجزء منها كامرأة  إنه تحد كبير
أن تكون ابنة وتسعة في
عائلة مع تسعة أشقاء ، كنا خمسة
أخت وأربعة أشقاء ، وكانت
موهبة أخرى أننا كنا في المركز
الخامس في عائلتي ، أخونا الأكبر
اسمه علي
، كان ليكسي ، قلها.  في المنزل ، لكننا
محظوظون بما يكفي لأن يكون لدينا والدنا كان
دائمًا يذكر في الخارج أخي لو
سيدتي آندي هاي مارك هاس سقط
تحت دوميني ، مرحبًا منزل الكوع إلى
سجادة يوجا هومو بوم معها لذلك كنا
محميين للغاية  في المنزل تحت
جناح والدي ، لذلك كان التحدي
مرة أخرى للتأكد من أنك تستحق تلك
الثقة بأنك تستحق تلك الحماية ،
لذلك كان علينا أن نبذل قصارى جهدنا لنستحق
دعمه ومهما قدمه لنا والدنا
مرة أخرى هذا هو  قناة أخرى لتكون
أخت لأخ يدعى الأب جافيا لايف
أب الآن أنا أفهم لماذا اعتاد
أن يحمينا سنهز كل
شيء ونهز به خاصة بعد وفاة
والدي وهو كاذب هيما
وكان صعبًا جدًا أكثر من بلدي.  أبي قبل
أن أتزوج ولدي ابنتي ،
تبلغ من العمر سبع سنوات ، سارة ، لم
أفهم كم هي ثمينة لك
كم هو ثمين كم هو صعب أن
تعتني بأشياء ثمينة في
حياتك مثل أخواتك أخوك
والآن  ابنتي الآن أعطي أخي
علي كل المبالغة عندما اعتاد أن
يخبرني أن ميريام آبي اللطيفة الآخرون هم
الكفار في شوارعي هنا في ريو ، يا حبيبتي ،
يا فتاة ناريش كوني ، نعم ، التي في
الخلف تأخذ العسل ، كيف سيعني إذا
كان  في هذه الأثناء ، أنهيت كينيث ماجيو هذا العام
إيما التي يمكن أن تستمر في الحصول
على الجزء الأكثر تحديًا من
علاقتي بأخي علي الذي
أستحقه مرة أخرى ولدي ثقة طلبت منه أن
يفتح بابًا من الباب لي
وفتحه و  كان
يراقبني في كل خطوة
والحمد لله
قريبًا جدًا فتح لي الباب
وطلب مني أن أطير بعيدًا
ليس فقط للدخول في
و في المهنة وفي طريقي
مرة أخرى هناك آخر  أتحدى أن أكون
زوجة كامرأة كنت أخبرك بفخر
أن زوجي هو رقم
27 من اقتراحي لذا حصلت على 26 عرضًا
وكان كارا
رقم 27 كان محظوظًا ،
هل تعتقد أنني أخبره دائمًا
أنك محظوظ بذلك  قلت لك نعم ، لكن
صدقني كنت
أسعد امرأة حظًا في العالم
ليكون كريم زوجي لأنني
أقول له حقًا شكرًا جزيلاً لك على
كل دعمك لي عندما أتى
بالاقتراح السابق أياً كان من يأتي
اقترح لي كنت أسأل  لهم شرط واحد
اعتدت أن أخبر عمي خافيير همنديز
قاصر بريوني لهم أن يحشدوا فكرة أو
ساحة في السنة و D قاصر في
Waspey Basilio في السيارة الأخرى هو مدمن
ما غزنه وعلماء التكنولوجيا العسكريون
مضحك أن يدفعه بيلاجيا إنه
Isetta يصدر أي شيء -
يستطيع Pablo حاليًا الحياة المسرحية / من تشغيل
فيديو جيد ما هي الفكرة - ماراثون O'Hara
Iago مع مرافقة أو خيوط مع
Calum و Royale mob decker1 هو كيف أكره
أن أغفر قاعدة طبية على Thero
a  يا فتاة ، إنها تريد منحنى
Sangha karma للبكتيريا المتعرجة
والبكتيريا ذات الأصل اللاتيني مارلين سي
ساكت أكثر من ذلك بقليل مارا الوسطى ، نحن
دايهان فيكاري دائمًا ، لذلك علينا أن
نقول شكرًا لجميع السادة في
حياتنا بسبب  أنني أصر دائمًا على
أنه يجب علينا كامرأة أن نكون
ممتنين جدًا لكل الأشياء الإيجابية في
حياتنا ، وعلينا أن نكون ممتنين
لجميع السادة الذين أحاطوا بنا في
حياتنا وكانوا السبب الرئيسي وراء
نجاحنا.  ess مرة أخرى كأم ، كان هذا
تحديًا آخر ، لقد كنت محظوظًا بما فيه الكفاية
مع المواد النووية الخاصة
بأصهارتي ، كنت فتاة شقية ، مثل Elberton
Abbeville ، Juana
Vito Heywood ، في دور Manticore قليلاً
كاراتيه ، دعنا نقول أننا نتعاون مع الجنون
كلير ليس كونين Zedekiah
هناك فرق كبير بين
الزوجة الذكية والزوجة من أجل التوقف لتكون زوجة ذكية ،
عليك التأكد من أنك
ذكي بما يكفي في حياتك الاجتماعية ، كنت
ذكيًا لأتأكد من أنني لا أريد
منزلًا خاصًا أريده  أعيش مع
أصهاري
لمجرد أنني أعلم أنني سأسافر قريبًا جدًا
إلى الخارج وأواصل دراستي
وأبحاثي الجينية والأمراض الوراثية ، لذلك
كنت محظوظًا بزوجتي التي
كانت حماتي تعتني بها.
ابنتي سارة وهي تتأكد من
تعليمها كل الأشياء الجيدة أحد
الأشياء التي أنا فخور بها أيضًا
لابنتي سارة مرة أخرى
تبلغ من العمر سبع سنوات
نحن مغاربة وصلنا في العارضات
مع محررنا يقول إنني ابتكر عمري
مثل أميليا  كرمة واسعة ميلانيا إلهة
لها  في أي تربية بهلوي
تررم ديمتري هي Mythili في الفندق
وعودًا بشحن قريب من رعاية الحياة حولها
مروان كيلي مريم المصطلح البريطاني هو
إسكوبار هارتمان متجهًا إلى
سيرينا ذات العيار العالي وواضح لمقبض فظيع
أقل من اللعين إذا
عاد هو ووكالة ناسا  لقد كرهته بتأخير
شاي مقصورتها المعينة ، وكان هناك تحدٍ آخر نظيف
، يجب أن أذهب كثيرًا إلى اليابان للحصول على
درجة الدكتوراه.أنا أحصل على درجة الدكتوراه في الأمراض
الوراثية على مدار العامين الماضيين وسبعة أشهر ،
لذا يجب أن أتحدث كثيرًا إلى
اليابان  وإحدى الرحلات التي تناقش مرة أخرى
خطة دراستي بالكامل عندما
عدت كانت المرة الأولى التي أرحل فيها
، عدت إلى المنزل وكانت ابنتي
تتصل بي ،
لقد كان الأمر مؤلمًا للغاية لدرجة أنها كانت تهتم بها
وما زالت مرحبًا بي.  يتي
، كان الأمر مؤلمًا جدًا في تلك المرة التي
اتصلت بي ابنتي بها ، وعندما
جاءت حماتي وقالت
يا مايا كان الأمر مؤلمًا للغاية في ذلك الوقت ،
قررت أن أتأكد من أنني أعطي
ابنتي القدر المناسب
من الدعم  وكل الروابط الاجتماعية
التي تستحقها
صدقني أنه ليس من السهل أن تكون امرأة
في كل زاوية ، فهناك تحد كبير
ولكن عليك أن تتأكد من أنك
اكتسبت كل المهارات التي
ستساعدك على المضي قدمًا في هذا إن شاء الله.
امرأة يمثل تحديًا كبيرًا آخر
لقد قمت بقيادتي من
جامعة هارفارد في القيادة وخلال
مسار القيادة لم تكن هناك
محاضرة واحدة حول القيادة في النساء أو
النساء مع القيادة
وخلال مسيرتي المهنية لاحظت أن هناك
فرقًا كبيرًا في قراري وجميع
لنفترض أن القرار الخاطئ
الذي اتخذته في حياتي خاصة في الحياة
المهنية كان مرتبطًا بفترة
الحيض لدي كما تعلمون ، فكل امرأة
سيكون لديها خمسة أيام إلى سبعة أيام
في الشهر تحت سيطرة
هرمون الاستروجين.
ستحصل السيدة على مستوى عالٍ
جدًا وستحصل على فترة لانيسا تخشى LaMotta من
تفاقم Recife a loopy idle
Mafi جيدًا عندما أكون Heather أنا في
كولورادو يمكن أن يحد  وبصحة جيدة ، إما
أن مارا سأخشى الأم في ماناسا
مع الفكرة عندما مات المعلم
البوليميريز الثاني ، فقد أكد في أواتا
لابوف أنه سيحدث الشريان السباتي في
محاولة لفكرة قطعها عندما اعتقدت
أنها كانت شريعة ولكوكومو كيواني على
بعد كيلومتر من الكافيين  لدي أي
شاب وكنت هناك فقط تحدث روجر
يا شجاعة أو جانبها يوجين
لولا لم أعذر عمي ،
دعني أفوز في مارا وماراثي سأكون
في ديبورا الشريعة أوه ويليام
الإسكافي دورا أوه حسنًا يا رجلك  دقيقة
Dora Matt kun-hee نعم
سألتقي معلمي Gong Gong الذي أنوراك فاهيني
لطيف للغاية والكروشيه من منزلنا مع Heather
Locklear Aberdeen سيكون لدي
آخر حول أنني حصلت على
عامل موريسون ثنائي الاتجاه adora Sharia الذي
اتخذته الكتيبة  لها وكذلك المملكة المتحدة واحدة
Atman والتعليق على هاواي مريح
لها عملوا هناك في والدتها
فيما بعد اعتبروا فصلها مو وليس
عند الإعلان في
هذا التجمع أود أن أرسل
رسالة لجميع النساء و l  القيادة
أو في تدريب أو في موقف
يحتاجون فيه إلى اتخاذ قرار ، يرجى
التأكد من أن تكون مدركًا وموجهًا بالكامل بشأن
موقفك المصغر إذا كنت في
اليوم الأول في اليوم الثاني أو اليوم الثالث حاول
تأجيل أي قرار حاول اتخاذه
بمجرد أن تشعر أنك أفضل بكثير
والانتفاخ أقل من جسمك ،
انظر مرة أخرى كامرأة ، إنه تحد كبير
في كل زاوية ، هناك
تحد جديد لك وكامرأة
يجب أن تكون مثل قطرة ماء أنت  يجب
أن أكون
صوتًا رقيقًا ولطيفًا أتذكر أنه حتى اليوم
لم يُسمح لنا برفع صوتنا في
المنزل في صيغة المنحنى يمكننا أن
نفتحها وحقيقية في إندونيسيا ونرتبها hydroid لمريادا حتى أننا
لا نخطي في nano gov jennifer نفسك
booyah
حسنًا ، أنا لم ألغى
تفكيرك ، إنه معدن قليل العدد مع اليد الرئيسية
ولكننا هاجمنا وابل الأحذية
ولكن مو تي وهتلر يعترض على إلهنا جيدًا ،
أود أن أقول إننا أؤمن بأنني
رأيت حركة المرور قليلاً في  غير متجانسة
رهيب م  تم تسليم essy room con hakuna
إلى محامي فريق العمل الخاص
بي لمدة عام مضى
بالفعل وكانت العاصفة عبارة عن نظرية واحدة ، لذا من
المهم جدًا أن تدرك
أنك امرأة تحتاج إلى حل وتحتاج
إلى الاعتناء بنفسك
تحتاج إلى  كن مثل قطرة ماء
وأنت بحاجة إلى أن تكون شفافًا ، كيف حالك
مافيا المال LM Nasser ، لا يوجد
شيء أفضل من أن تكون شفافًا
كن على طبيعتك حتى اليوم ليس لدي
درج مقفل أو خزانة
Lilliana ومخادعة ، ها ها ها ها ها ها ها ها ها ها ها ها ها ها ها ها ها نشطة
المافيا
hellovenus مافيا لدينا هيلينا ، لذا دكتورة ماسي ، إنها غرزة شفة
، ستسمح الحزمة للخوف مع
دورين في مكان مثل هذا
لدينا وشعرت أنه في ذلك الوقت
لا يمكنك أن تكون شفافًا ، لا تمضي
قدمًا وهذا  تأكد من هذه الخطوة
وأقول لك إنها
ليست الطريقة الصحيحة حيث يوجد شيء
مريب أو خاطئ يحدث ، لذا حاول أن تكون
شفافًا قدر الإمكان يمكنك
الحفاظ على أنوثتك والحفاظ على
ماضيك من خلال حياتك المهنية  ما
نعده ضروريًا جدًا لاستدامة الحياة ،
لذا تأكد من أن الجميع سيعرفون
أنك ثمين جدًا ، دع قطرة
الماء ومرة أخرى كقطرة ماء
يجب أن نكون ونتأكد من أننا
أقوياء كما تعلمون قطرة ماء ماذا
يفعل ما يمكن أن يفعله بحجر ، هل يمكنك أن
تعرف كيف أن قطرة الماء قوية بدرجة
كافية وتستمر في نفس الجانب
يمكنها أن تفعل شيئًا
لا تستطيع العصا العادية القيام به وهذا أحد
الإنجازات التي أنا فخور بها للغاية
أود أن أشاركها
معك في عام 2006 ، لقد شاركت كثيرًا
في مشروع يسمى UAE Free من Della
Samia 2012 وأحضرتني إلى هذه
النقطة لمجرد أنني كنت أعرف أن هناك البعض في
مكان ما مثل قبرص على مدار الـ 23
عامًا
الماضية  ليس هناك طفل واحد ولد مع
سامية لمجرد أنهم
فعلوا ذلك الوعي وتأكدوا من إجراء
فحص قبل أن يتزوج أي شخص على
أرضهم ، لذلك لم يكن هناك شيء في ذلك الوقت
وأنا أقول بفخر أنني كنت
أحد أسباب ذلك  ص  تمت الموافقة على
قانون وتشريعات التحقيق في الزواج من
قبل مجلس الوزراء ، وقد
تشرفت بما يكفي لأكون في ذلك الوقت في
اجتماع مجلس الوزراء حيث وافقوا على هذا
التشريع ، ولم أفعل ذلك بمفردي ،
لكنني بدأت وكان لدي فريق جيد جدًا
يؤمن بما  نحن نقوم بذلك
والآن لن يتزوج أحد في
الإمارات العربية المتحدة ما لم يتم
فحصهم بحثًا عن اضطراب وراثي شائع
بدأنا في عام 2007 وأردت 3600
عينة فقط وتطوعت
للتقدم للفحص لمعرفة مستوى هذا
المرض الوراثي في الإمارات العربية المتحدة تخيل  بالنسبة
للموعد النهائي في 12/12/2012 حتى قبل عام 2009 ،
ربما
كان هناك حاجة عند 3600 ، لكنني فخور
جدًا بالقول إننا تمكنا حتى الآن من
فحص أحد عشر ألفًا ومائتين
وثمانية ، وبهذا نكون
عينة  من جميع أنحاء الإمارات العربية
المتحدة من أبو ظبي حتى الفجيرة
كم وفرنا من المال
للبلد وكم عدد الحالات التي تمكنا من
تشخيصها كما ترون من بين إحدى عشرة
ألف ومائتين وواحد وثمانين
عينة أربعة  أصيب مائة وثمانية وسبعون
منهم ، فنحن نحمل
جين مرض الثلاسيميا الذي
سيزيد من فرصة إصابة جيلهم الجديد
بالمرض
2210 إلى خلية منجل 219 مع
g6pd وهذا يكلفنا فقط أربعة ملايين
ونصف.  ذهبت إلى
هيئة الصحة بدبي فقلت له هل يمكنك أن تخبرني في عام
2007 سبب إدارة إحدى هذه
الحالات كم كلفتك
التكلفة 35 ألفًا وثمانمائة وخمسين
لقد ضربتها في تلك
الأرقام التي نعرفها جيدًا  لن
تعاني بعد الآن ، يمكنك أن تتخيل
مقدار ما وفرناه من أموال للبلد
وهذا يعتمد على أساس سنوي دون النظر
إلى التكلفة الأخرى للدعم الاجتماعي كما
قلنا 32 مليون درهم
بينما أنفقنا أربعة ملايين
ونصف فقط وهذا شيء آخر  الإنجاز الذي
تمكنا من القيام به هو أحد
الشرائح التي كنت سأُنهي فيها عرضي
التقديمي مع أعتذر ، لقد استغرقت
2-3 دقائق لكنني كنت تحت
تأثير د.  عبد الله في البداية تم
تكريمنا بما فيه الكفاية هذا العام مركزنا
الواقع في دبي يتعلق بشكل أساسي
بالبحث الجيني
سيرينا صدقة جارية وروجرز إيدلر
هيما ورئيسنا لديه سمو
الشيخ في هانيانغ نقوم بإجراء جميع الاختبارات
مجانًا لمن يعيش في الإمارات العربية المتحدة.
بحاجة إلى تأشيرة إقامة
وسيهتم سموه بجميع
تكاليف هذا الفحص ، لذلك قمنا بإجراء
تلك الفحوصات وتم
التعرف على مختبرنا من قبل ثلاثة
مراكز أبحاث دولية وفي أحد
الاجتماعات في المؤتمر كنت أتحدث
عن مختبرنا  في
عرض تقديمي أكثر علمية حيث
تشرفت بما يكفي ليكون لدي خمسة من الحائزين على
جائزة
نوبل مهتمين بالقدوم وزيارة مختبرنا الصغير ،
هذا حتى لا يأتي في الحلم الذي
تعلم أنه يمكنك الحصول على واحد أو اثنين ولكن ليس
خمسة منهم جاءوا طوال الطريق
وهم  زرت معملنا الصغير ،
سأنهي هذا الحديث
بتعليقهم ، لقد أمضوا ساعة في
مركزنا الصغير وقالوا إن AEG da هو
بقعة ضوء في العالم العربي  والثانية في
البحث الجيني وخمسة منهم
وقعوا على سجل الزوار هذا كل ما
يمكنني قوله وأنا أعتذر إذا لم أكن
أركز في البداية ، شكرًا جزيلاً لك